allora quanto manca il titolo del mio
intervento quanto manca per 15 minuti
alla fine dell'intervento
generalmente la domanda che si fanno i
bambini
quanto manca quando io ero bambino che
devo a mio padre quanto manca per
arrivare a quando eravamo in macchina
come meta a cui si voleva
arrivare con naturalmente tutto
l'entusiasmo dei bambini o questo
entusiasmo continuo a tenerlo nonostante
siano almeno 25 quasi 30 anni ormai che
lavoro nel mercato del city e vi volevo
raccontare brevissimamente negli anni a
metà sostanzialmente degli anni ottanta
cavallo degli anni 80 90
io ho lavorato per quasi dieci anni nel
laboratorio di intelligenza artificiale
della gp spa quindi della società che
faceva
esplorazione e produzione di di petrolio
in queste condizioni
quindi non c'era internet non c'erano i
cellulari c'era però già l'open source e
anche si chiamava più semplicemente free
software che nasce come sapete tutti
alle m.it quindi nel dipartimento di
intelligenza artificiale peraltro
si doveva ancora fermare oracle con i
database relazionali che oggi i database
sono nove se quello è sempre andato a
bere relazionale ti dicono che sei
arretrato la durata dei progetti era di
minimo progetti di ricerca applicata di
tre anni potenza di calcolo poker
risorio
anche la memoria di massa naturalmente
si doveva mettere molta intelligenza nei
programmi quindi si usava la
programmazione logica si facevano però
anche le prime cose di image processing
o di audio processing
naturalmente solamente beccia perché in
tempo reale non era assolutamente
fattibile e si cominciavano a fare già
le prime cose di machine learning cioè
delle macchine che apprendono la sola ai
famosi reti neurali piuttosto i
programmi che apprendono dall'esperienza
a risolvere
i problemi e forse tutti voi ricorderete
adesso non ricordo bene ranno ma credo
che sia verso metà degli anni novanta
deep blue dbm vince per la prima volta a
scacchi contro un campione del mondo
anche se molti dicono che fosse truccato
c'era molta intelligenza in in quei
programmi oggi
evidentemente tutto cambiato ma alcune
cose sono rimaste le stesse oggi
internet e mobile ce l'avete tutto il
traffico prevalentemente
video ci sono le reti le reti sociali
il costo della potenza di calcolo e
della memoria sono risibili rispetto
agli anni passati anche se nell'ultima
presentazione sappiamo che si può
migliorare ancora tantissimo
l'imex processing si fa in tempo reale
una start up a in tempo di lancio tra i
36 mesi contro appunto il minimo di tre
anni dei progetti di ricerca di allora
si sono affermati si stanno affermando i
big data ne avete sentito parlare prima
ci sono quindi tantissimi dati oggi è
impossibile vincere a scacchi ma non è
basato sull'intelligenza è basato
sostanzialmente su algoritmi di machine
learning è anche impossibile vincere a
backgammon
sapete che backgammon ha poi quelle
stelle elemento di aleatorietà perché si
lanciano dei dati non c'è campione che
sia in grado ormai i tornei si fanno tra
macchine tra programmi
eppure eppure
eppure i problemi dell'uomo continuano
quelli più gravi continuare a essere gli
stessi avete sentito anche prima cibo e
acqua che sono le due facce di uno di
uno stesso problema avete sentito prima
che appunto nell'arco di 20 anni
io forse ce ne ho trenta
arriveremo a 9 miliardi oggi siamo 7
miliardi
naturalmente
continuiamo ancora oggi nonostante la
tecnologia a compromettere gli eco
gli ecosistemi noi siamo dei parassiti
si l'avete sentito dire
dire oggi è il problema paradossalmente
per quanto ci presentino le pubblicità
con queste campagne bellissime queste
famiglie con i figli biondi
straordinarie eccetera eccetera e
proprio l'agricoltura
consuma pensate il 70 per cento
dell'acqua dolce e di questo nel mondo
he e di questo 70 per cento il 50 per
cento è totalmente buttato
per molti motivi consuma negli stati
uniti il 20 per cento del petrolio
riduce soprattutto negli stati uniti la
biodiversità perché sono magari 50.000
ettari di monocultura in alcune in
alcune zone
l'italia una situazione l'avete sentito
prima di biodiversità decisamente
migliore figlia di una tradizione
agricola di un certo tipo ce l'hanno ce
l'hanno spiegato ci hanno spiegato prima
pensate che la dimensione media di
un'impresa agricola italiana è intorno
ai 20 ha la media di germania e francia
intorno ai 50 ettari che la dimensione
la dimensione media al sud e
naturalmente siamo messi peggio che al
nord al nord è un po più alta al sud è
un po più bassa
gli imprenditori agricoli sono
mediamente anziani più anziani del resto
degli imprenditori agricoli d'europa al
sud sono un po più giovani per il
semplice motivo che non esiste lavoro
nelle città
questa è l'agricoltura non parla
dell'allevamento perché personalmente lo
ritengo una cosa primitiva allevare
degli animali per macellarli a quella
maniera qualcosa che proprio a me
personalmente per quanto io sia
dipendente tanto dal fumo di sigaretta
dalla carne la continua a ritenere una
cosa primitiva io spero che prima o poi
si affermino le cosiddette costituzioni
ibride nel numero di marzo che uscirà a
breve francesco monico parla proprio di
queste costituzioni
ibride è una rivista tosto nota di di
filosofia io spero che entro vent'anni
le bistecche si possono produrre che non
le stampanti 3d
la ritengo una cosa possibile
e veniamo alle città perché da una parte
abbiamo la cultura e dall'altra parte
abbiamo le le città il 50 per cento
della popolazione mondiale
vive nelle città e nei sobborghi urbani
è la tendenza è naturalmente all'aumento
si parla di stime che nell'arco di dieci
anni saranno intorno al 60 per cento io
penso adesso non ho il dato magari il
professore si credo che in italia siamo
già oggi intorno al 60 per cento quindi
è necessario estendere ulteriormente
l'agricoltura perché abbiamo bisogno di
più cibo è più cibo si ottiene almeno a
prima secondo la tradizione diciamo
ormai di decine di migliaia di anni
attraverso l'agricoltura in terra
che comporta però aumentare l'uso di
fertilizzanti di pesticidi e quindi
compromettere ancora di più gli
ecosistemi naturali
il paradosso è quindi che dobbiamo
riparare e proteggere l'ambiente da una
parte
ma dobbiamo produrre abbastanza cibo per
la popolazione mondiale questi due
obiettivi sembrano essere come dire
mutualmente
esclusivi e bisogna trovare una
rivoluzione copernicana
una rivoluzione copeco copernico è un
personaggio a cui io mi ispiro sempre
quando vede un problema grosso che non
riesco complesso che non riesco a
risolvere cerco di capire se invertendo
il sole con la terra si si si riesca a
ottenere qualcosa
in italia abbiamo avuto la fortuna
proprio la facoltà di agraria di pisa di
questo personaggio fra come a santini
che è morto un po di anni fa che ha
inventato lario monica che forse il
sistema più efficiente l'altro mezzo el
idroponica insieme permettono di portare
con la rivoluzione copernicana
l'agricoltura in città e liberare i
campi sia con queste appunto vertical
farm che eventualmente con degli orti
urbani o immaginatevi delle stazioni
idroponiche delle dimensioni di poco più
di un frigorifero o di un frigorifero
all'interno della vostra della vostra
casa
nell'andare a cercare un po di
informazione sulle idroponica ero pony
che vi imbatterete sicuramente in un
altissima densità
tecnologica
io persino trovato questo
a milano la prima vertical farm del
mondo questo è il classico annunci smo
lo chiamo io anche perché oggi con con
gli strumenti della virtù reality dei di
del 3d si riesce a far finta che che la
realtà esista già quando ancora non
esiste non c'è nessun progetto di questo
tipo è semplicemente un annunci smo
sulla destra invece
vedete appunto un esempio di idroponica
questo è un progetto recentissimo è
ancora un prototipo del della hyundai le
tecnologie utili del ai siti a questo il
motivo per cui mi ci sono messo a
supporto di questa rivoluzione
copernicana esistono si chiamano
internet of things per gestire tutta la
sensoristica cioè noi immergiamo i
nostri sensi e non solo perché
naturalmente si arriva a misurare
come dire quantità di biologiche anche
che noi non saremo in grado con i nostri
cinque sensi di cogliere big data
ovviamente machine learning perché
dovremmo imparare quali sono i profili
ottimali del pomodoro di pachino in
termini di temperature di precipitazioni
di luce quindi anche d'età visualizza
perché poi noi vogliamo capire quei dati
che cosa significano in questo senso io
credo è uno dei problemi più grossi che
abbiamo in italia che non abbiamo
nessuna credibilità come
operatori dell'information technology ci
siamo credibili e lo dico da tanti anni
come un tedesco nella moda
poco quindi bisogna come dire in qualche
misura nascondere la tecnologia in un
veicolo che invece nel mondo ancora
successo
che appunto il cosiddetto made in italy
in particolare nel contesto di questo di
questo progetto che su cui stiamo
lavorando
c'è ovviamente tutto il discorso del
design pensate le vertical farms sono
sostanzialmente dei grattacieli dove si
coltivano
gli ortaggi ma anche molto di più anche
i funghi in modo assolutamente privo di
terra e
l'architettura
qualcosa noi italiani in qualche
credibilità ce l'abbiamo ancora anche
grazie a personaggi anche di oggi come
renzo piano per esempio c'è il design
proprio anche degli apparati dei
frigoriferi anche questa è una cosa
importante poi il food italy sapete a
un certo successo sta aprendo negozi
ovunque nel mondo io ho coinvolto in
questo progetto un grande architetto
italiano poco noto in italia ma appena
vinto la gara per il rifacimento del del
palazzo dell'onu a ginevra costruisce
grattacieli in
in qatar gli ho mandato un'email e lui
mi ha risposto così ve la leggo perché
vale la pena le serre verticale
rappresentano il futuro delle megalopoli
ci saranno mega blocks con quattro torri
2 per abitare una per lavorare è una per
produrre cibo tutto finisce nel podium e
nel basement che le uniscono dove
insieme alle fasi liti pubbliche
culturali sport e sociali c'è anche il
mercato e ristoranti basta trasporti
urbani per niente sono parti e foreste
fuori non campi coltivati
ricordatevi che una volta che noi
arretriamo dalla natura la natura torna
a curare se stessa quindi con il ciclo
della
della natura della clorofilla della
fotosintesi che ricomincia a curare se
stessa e curare anche anche anche noi ci
stiamo lavorando insieme ovviamente
immaginatevi che un progetto di vertical
farm è un progetto di decine di milioni
di dollari di o di euro che ha anche
bisogno di
come dire un po supporto e un patrocinio
evidentemente di natura amministrativa
politica
vedremo se ce la facciamo l'altro no
l'altro si può fare sono già quasi
pronto con un prototipo
quindi spero nei prossimi mesi diciamo
entro l'anno di riuscire a come dire a
contribuire a
riparare la natura io ho finito grazie